[Music]
an unexpected ending news submitted by
air guitar Championships a recent humans
of New York Post has gone viral for the
disturbing details of a man's story
honi loved humans of New York I loved
onei - I stopped straight to how I do
that I got bored what is it for those of
us humans in New York it's a Instagram
page or like the buzz social media pages
um so this guy he's a photographer and
he goes and he photographs people and
then he like interviews them a little
bit and he gets like a small sliver of
their life into this caption sometimes
it's really late oh wow
I just unfollowed as you were saying
that oh yeah and by now he travels the
world so it's not just New York it's
like humans a Pettis Maisie
mm-hmm well right now well this one was
from Montreal and so this is the photo
this is what he looked this photo looks
like and I will read the cut not a sword
or umbrella ass or a cane I have no idea
I think it's the sword
the sheath alright so the caption says
and then this is the person in the photo
usually it's like we're reading their
thing okay so it says you could make a
horror movie about my life my mom died
of cancer when I was five and my father
tortured me
I mean tortured really tortured chained
me to a chair slapped me with leather it
was like Jack Nicholson in the shining
every single day he'd never said say a
thing he just kicked on my door and come
after me I was born into hell I spent 12
years alone with a demonic presence and
now I'm nervous really nervous I play
the piano to calm myself down I always
have these thoughts they aren't even my
thoughts fat [ __ ] [ __ ] bastards
[ __ ] them all they're my father's
thoughts the violence is inside of me my
energy is black black black I used to
kill little birds when I was a kitten I
thought then
then I moved on to cats by the time I
was 17 I was beating the [ __ ] out of
everybody bigger than me taller than me
I didn't care it was more torture to
keep it inside if I kept the violence
inside I mutilate myself suicide myself
a few years ago I set a guy on fire it
was 3:00 a.m. he was passed out beneath
the bridge just some druggie I didn't
feel a thing
I felt like laughing if anything I felt
free hmm
wow I don't understand what the lesson
is here right usually there's like
yourself incriminating himself yeah but
now humans of [ __ ] Montreal probably
need to report this s like I confessed
everyone is pointing to the guy Brandon
Stanton which is a photographer behind
this project
everyone's like Brandon if you don't
report this dude then if you're doing a
disservice to the public yeah he's gonna
kill a person if he hasn't already yeah
but it's not a personnal fighter could
this guy be a transient man that has
mental health issues it's just rambling
absolutely but he should still see
something say something protecting a
source yeah because then is he breaking
the trust of a man I also think it's a
little bit off from what he's used to
doing cuz he'll do things that's more
insightful and like oh yeah like
sometimes like people will be touched by
certain people's stories and like
everyone would be like where can we
donate money to this person and then
he'll actually help people yeah but I
think a lot of lonely serial killers out
there like oh this is kind of nice like
that speaks to them like oh yeah cuz it
does start a discussion right but then
like it's one of those if you like you
can't do you can't just do this one cuz
it just makes people scared I just don't
understand the discussion that the
discussion is that people like this
exist and then how do you deal with that
mm-hmm or it can be it should have maybe
shouldn't he should have stopped and I
probably had that question there like
what do you guys think well he doesn't
really like what do you guys think he's
just evil
exist and it's smiling at it you see the
little purple devil emoji to field read
all of his posts arse he just listens to
their story and then he writes it maybe
you're saying it's not his place to be
like this guy's a murderer he's like I'm
just the messenger oh don't shoot
because he's like good she's pretty much
like a therapist right like if the
therapy if you tell a therapist like all
you see they're setting on fire they
can't report you to the cops because
there's a competition like this like
this type of like protecting your
sources like a question like if
something happens to this guy that
people be like I'm never telling you my
story what I take from this is serial
killers are made not born
do you think that's true yeah I think
environment has a lot to do with I mean
it's the nature versus nurture argument
right yeah if they didn't have that
trauma would they express themselves in
this way yeah that's usually what I see
in a lot of movies so you're right
probably right because you know what
they say about movies everything is real
no for real though even in a Dexter do
the TV show basically but yeah we got
like when you was a kid you like Bert
like witnessed people being tamed like
turn thought up have you ever had a
trauma bonding it's when someone who has
had trauma in childhood as an adult they
relate trauma to love because the trauma
usually came from someone closer than
their family so they'll be like even
though this person beats me or like my
new boyfriend beats me I see it as love
because my mom used to get beat and I
love my mom and I see that as love and
that's like trauma bonding oh yeah they
recreate past traumatic experiences yeah
because that is love to them oh but this
guy killed birds and then that like a
tall tale fashion setup humans by
actually someone someone commented this
is a textbook serial killer like if you
don't know her that way yo so what
happened have you reported on that's it
like she hasn't followed up with
anything on his Instagram or his Twitter
like he really hasn't commented on this
that I've seen at all and people are
just replying on Twitter later it's just
funny because it's so different from his
usual post it's like if if I was on a
park bench like this and in the caption
it said yo I just shot a dude last week
that's basically what people are taking
this as
that looks like a public piano public
area and he has a sword what kind of
toys there's a tattoo on the guy's leg
like he has things identify identifying
what do you think is what city are you
allowed to walk around what the medieval
looking dungeon sword like that maybe
Portland and he doesn't walk trains yeah
like this well do they look dirty to you
the whole the piano looks pretty
homeless sure has a Grim Reaper on it
got a cooler
it looks like the piano bench it's
painted I think plaid pants and mark
Montreal we could find this guy I'm
saying that they have those public
pianos around the world there all the
time that's some fans I just go to that
public piano in Montreal gets he just
[ __ ] chop somebody with that sword
and he went to go play the piano to
relax also that is not plastic like it
shouldn't he be like pulled over
carrying a [ __ ] sword around yeah
yeah yeah so if someone even tagged the
Montreal police on twitter to this this
post here and so they said that after
verification no such event has happened
in Montreal over the last few years and
no one claimed hadn't been filed but he
made it up but if it was another
transient guy like he could have been in
a different city that did it if you did
do it yeah that's right stuff an e like
unless you catch them doing the crime
you can't really you can't really
prevent crime you know you can't say
like this guy like rest them yeah before
he does the next crime
oh no how do we catch this guy that's
like you guys remember that Oh Jay
Simpson book where he wrote he wrote a
book called if I did it yeah and he
details everything about the murderer in
it yeah he did and just said if he if I
did it he did that yeah it's the same
kind of moral quandary thing where it's
like is this okay to do but just double
check that's how they got Ted Bundy to
confess is they had him speaking
third-person because in the
interrogation room he wouldn't say
anything and then when you they say well
if Ted was about to do it like what do
you think he would do it was I try it
would do it this way then we get in
trouble how come oh they didn't get in
trouble here because double jeopardy if
you're already proven innocent that's it
yeah even if he were to
it'd be like I didn't yep yep he
wouldn't go back to jail no but that's
why when he's doing another [ __ ] he just
goes to joke immediately he's in jail
now I guess he just got out he got out
he just got out and said he's got I'm
not Khloe Kardashian's dad and I have a
lot of revenge to do it's what he said
Oh Lord that's a threat he said I have a
lot of right it was revenge just wonder
who there was a [ __ ] bomb SNL sketch
about that were they had who still
watches acid not very often but I but I
found this one it's Keenan playing OJ
and he's on a date with like a
millennial chick and he's like so you
you don't watch the news or anything
like that right and she's like
absolutely not he's like okay thank God
okay I'm [ __ ] like I'd go on a date
it right how long have you been married
two years
okay it's a dating app oh yeah
I'm meeting up with my girl Oh creepy
but yeah so another tweets comment here
it says I hope you reported him to the
police it would be irresponsible if you
didn't and if you have details of crimes
that you're withholding from police I
was right and you have details of crimes
that you have we're holding for the
police do the right thing is more
important than content and clicks yeah
like that makes me think like is it real
not just that but like right now because
everything's being promoted on social
media like everything's just like it's
all out there like where do you where do
you draw the line in terms of like well
done this should be repercussions for
what you're saying
what was our guys thinking posting this
to was he like hey here comes the drama
or do you think he was just doing his
job
um knowing his brand and what he's done
like over the years I don't think his
whole thing was I'm gonna go viral
because he's already viral zoravar yeah
he's really well-known I mean his posts
been published to buy I think like major
media sites and whatever and he's just
the storyteller yeah so he doesn't need
the cloud no no I just think it's just
what he does is he just interviews and
talk to people and then he writes the
most interesting thing about them in the
caption and I think that was the most
interesting thing
their conversation that popped out that
he wrote into caption well it's also
interesting that doesn't sound like a
guy like he talks about the shining and
he speaks eloquently it doesn't sound
like a madman just like Maura barking
nothing it sounds like he told a
complete story in this caption which
makes it really cool yeah it's pretty
cookie cutter too like it's like almost
like a textbook like Law & Order episode
like serial killer no kind of thing I
don't know it's it's okay I always had a
feeling that he kind of yeah he tweaked
what people said to make it sound better
yeah I mean I don't even know you know
cuz has there been people coming out
saying like hey that was me and I didn't
say that
so I don't think that he changes what
they're saying I'm just saying like he's
not writing verbatim what he's saying
like is editing some of it likes making
it sound flowery yeah exactly that's
what I think you probably even know what
the guy looks like oh the humans a New
York guy I'll take my second record
right why do you say that because it's
interesting
only because I'm in front of the camera
of all these things that I do like
but there's other publications or like
teams out there that are in social media
and they're not their face isn't even in
on the thing yeah hold on and here okay
I get it
I'm just kidding no I didn't know that
like I don't know I yeah cuz I couldn't
tell if he was white or black or
whatever that just looks normal to me
but he's like no no he's got the e line
anything going on well I'm not he was
doing this he's look that that does look
like a cloud chaser me he doesn't write
he looks like um there's a guy getting
stories and pictures yeah one of you
makes money off of that Instagram he
does that books Oh cuz duh that's where
the money comes
[Music]
[Music]